on February 8 2018 a retired man living
in Suburban Georgia named Henri Norris
was watching the evening news in his
bedroom when he heard what sounded like
a bomb go off inside his house a team of
more than two dozen police officers had
set off flashbang grenades they broke
through every door of his home with
battering rams the officers were doing a
drug raid but they had the wrong house
when Nora sued his lawsuit was thrown
out because of a legal Doctrine called
qualified immunity which makes it
difficult for victims to hold state or
local government employees accountable
for violating their constitutional
rights we as a society
whether we like it or not are providing
these officers with their power their
discretion their Badges and their guns
and I believe that we as a society also
have a responsibility a shared
responsibility
to
make those people whole
when their rights have been violated